predictive modeling is a process of
modeling historical data for predicting
future events
for example we want to use electronic
health record that we have available to
view a model of heart failure
so that we can predict patients who are
at risk of developing heart failure
sooner
predictive modeling is not a single
algorithm but a computational pipeline
that involves multiple steps
the key goal we want to answer in this
lesson is how do we develop a good
predictive model
using electronic health record quickly
first we decide the prediction target
for example
whether a patient will develop heart
failure in the next few years
second we construct the cohort of
relevant patients for the study
third we define all the potentially
relevant features for the study
fourth we select which features are
actually relevant for predicting the
target
fifth we compute the predictive model
and sixth we evaluate the predictive
model
then we iterate this process several
times until we are satisfied with the
resulting model
prediction target there are often many
targets that an investigator wants to
predict
using the data they have however only a
subset of them are possible
so we should choose the prediction
target that addresses the primary
question that is both interesting to the
investigator and possible to be answered
using the data
in this lecture let's focus on
predicting the onset of heart failure
which is an interesting and potentially
possible target
motivations for early detection if we
want to develop a predictive model for
heart failure
what are the motivations for early
detection of heart failure
first heart failure is a complex disease
there is no widely accepted
characterization and definition of heart
failure
probably because the complexity of the
syndrome
it has many potential ideologies diverse
clinical features
and numerous clinical subsets if we can
detect heart failure earlier
we can potentially reduce the cost of
hospitalization associated with heart
failure
we can also potentially introduce new
early intervention to try to slow down
the progression of heart failure
improve the quality of life and reduce
mortality
in the long term we can improve existing
clinical guidelines for heart failure
prevention